[Music]
it's nine o'clock this is Metro radio
another mysterious stash of money's
turned up in a counter down village it's
their village their mystery but it just
keeps happening
someone's been leaving money around like
the streets and paper them find me 100
but no one's known who's doing us
there's been bundles of 20 pound noughts
beans found scattered all over black
hole caller last five years from 2014
has been 13 bundles of money which is
equal to twenty six thousand pound
Durham Police have examined the evidence
but with nobody here claiming the caches
theirs
they've just been handing it back to the
residents who found it
who do you think is leaving the money
there's a mystery of who it is but my
idea is someone who had had a great
childhood has come to make all of us
have them like the best childhood the
[ __ ] well I don't think it's someone
that lives a block I'll call over
because knuckle is the wealthiest
village people always think it's a man
because men get more suspicious
basically but but then it could also be
a woman maybe it might be over bear with
this some there's some people it is gone
he's like a hero
- oh the over like pure people how
honest are you and very honest but I
don't think everyone's been hiding a
name because you don't know if people's
handed it in a lot because they're
probably keeping a secret
there's certain people who aren't honest
and who would keep the money and there's
people who would be honest and take to
the police if you text to the police
they're just gonna give you a back so I
keep it because there's no point you're
gonna take it where two weeks and then
you're gonna get back anywhere if you
found the money in the street world your
face don't like
any of them could be the next lucky
finder so what would you do with the
money
cucumbers because I love cucumber
I would ask my mom my dad if I could buy
an RV it's a car it's a car that have a
house inside probably give it a half of
it to charity and then I'd put the other
half to like do good so help with us
spend on health free zoo foods and
healthy drinks and give it to people a
spa
I'd guess some ice skating lessons then
I'd put a thousand pound away for
holiday you wouldn't give it away
no could've think you're it's you're so
like why would you want to give them
what are you we're weird
it is weird the last stash was left here
next to the tribute to black holes
mining heritage this is an easier way to
earn money but they'd still like to know
where it's from Tom Parmenter skynews
County Durham